wo ist dein ding
[Musik]
ich hätte gerne einen kaffee aber zum
mitnehmen bitte
das ist mir zu laut das verstehe ich
mache ihm den kaffeeklatsch fertig das
stark macht nicht wahnsinnig also ich
habe die blumen mitgebracht und ein
schlechtes gewissen ist weil ich nicht
mehr mit dir' streiten müll
und
wie läuft sonst so mehr kunden hat sich
ja schon aber bekomme ich bei diesen
lärm auch nicht es ist ja so laut wie
hier auf einer autobahn
nein es ist sogar so laut ihrem
flughafen
ich glaube ich ziehe ausland wir sind
die mieten auch günstiger es hier um ein
studios rams ich finde es viel schöner
auf dem land
dass dort weniger verkehr außerdem ist
die luft besser und das ist mit
sicherheit auch viel leiser lässt
ich lebe doch viel lieber in der stadt
als auf dem land für mich ist es wichtig
dass ich abends mal schnell raus gehen
und freunde treffen oder ins kino gehen
kann
das ist ein klarer vorteil der stadt du
kannst auf dem land genauso gut abends
weggehen wie hier neustadt und gesten zu
deinen nachbarn
ich kenne meine nachbarn doch gar nicht
statt nicht aber auf dem land gibt es
keine kinos und keine theater keine bars
zwei adresse